let's let's stick with the president so
he decided this week to give back five
percent of his salary because of the
sequester he thought that would be a
nice little gesture to the furloughed
workers and five percent of his four
hundred thousand dollar a year salary is
about twenty thousand bucks John Kerry
the Secretary of State also did it now
he only makes a cool 180 thousand a year
so that was about nine thousand bucks
now he's worth you know he's married to
Korea Heinz ketchup you can't get
ketchup in this country without going
through John Kerry he's worth about 200
million bucks gave nine thousand dollars
so are things like this is this your
he's a real gamers unite could have
given everyone at the State Department
free ketchup for life or something that
would have been more worthy than 9,000
us I mean are these things just silly
little token yes that it and it's just
nothing more than that like let's deal
with the economy let's uh get rid of
corporate tax loopholes like if Obama
was actually a fighter in in terms of
raising revenue through taxing the rich
you know their fair share of taxes and
getting rid of these ridiculous
deductions that wealthy people get to
take advantage of then I would give him
like a round of applause but this is
like okay so you're giving up twenty
thousand dollars a year you cares you're
still tremendously wealthy does does the
carry one seem worse to you because of
how much he's worth I mean nine thousand
bucks uh is well he but he was uh he was
against giving back the money before he
was obviously no yeah um what why I
think while they're why they're doing
this is because whoever whichever
political party gets tagged with the
most of the responsibility for the
sequester as these cuts actually start
to be felt which are starting to be felt
now uh so that's why they're doing the
sea look we're the good guys it's the
sequester is in our Father that's why
the Republicans keep saying the
President Obama wanted this this is his
idea was his idea and so they're all
trying to try to get to get away from
this they're trying to get distance from
it and this is the way Barack Obama's
administration has decided see we're not
we're taking the cut to or we're with
you or with the people not like the
other and it but two people fall for
that cuz it strikes me as such a
disingenuous
thing I mean the money means nothing to
him he obviously is not walking around
day to day pulling any cash out of his
pocket and spending a dime so it seems
disingenuous but you think they're just
the pr oh yes it's just it isn't mean
it's you know most a lot of the stuff
that happens in Washington is some you
know politically symbolic and it's but
it's also important I think it is
important to show that hey we're with
you we're not ignoring that you guys are
hurting but it but it is Barack Obama's
Paul I mean people it is his fault
because we should have never had the
sequester in the first place because she
should never caved to those idiots in
the first place when they said they
weren't gonna raise the debt ceiling and
by negotiating over that he said a
horrible precedent well now he says he's
not good anymore I already screwed up
bad enough so I'm not gonna do that
again yeah he felt like Bob Woodward how
do i yeah I think he's setting a
terrible precedent right now with the
grand bargain I mean the the GOP has
basically rejected the grand bargain but
Obama is basically saying you know what
I want to increase revenue so it's
increased taxes on the wealthy but I'm
totally willing to make cuts to Social
Security and Medicare which are called
entitlement programs because we are
freakin entitled to it we've paid into
that system we shouldn't be cutting it
at all that shouldn't even be on the
table nope they're not drivers of the
debt right so Saturday exactly no bet
Social Security has its own trust fund
right you know and and if you're also
solvent until 20 23 by the way so this
is this is all manufacture these are
just people who don't like social
programs and then Barack Obama gives
credence to it and goes along with it so
yeah do you think part of the problem is
that we just go from crisis to crisis
that we don't have any we clearly have
no long you know we had a fiscal cliff
that no one had even heard of the phrase
fiscal cliff until the fiscal cliff
happened two weeks before and then it
went to hashtagged on Twitter everyone
knew what it was and then the sequester
which no one had heard of the sequester
like we just do this we manufacture
these things and then and it's the way
that we actually get nothing done but
everyone screams about all that
absolutely and it's it's this cycle that
I just cannot handle any more like it's
to the point where you know that it's an
important topic you want to pay close
attention to it because it has to do
with your livelihood as a member of the
middle class or working class but at the
same time you know exactly how it's
going to play out because we've seen it
over and over again I just
I get distracted by her beauty and a
woman did just walk by I was like wait I
could totally feel a jimmy dore not
paying attention what I'm saying right
now I was looking at your necklace in
the monitor and I was like that is a
nice nugget Thank You Jimmy if you're
the best big guns a call back to the
previous segment which you can probably
see below right the second alright last
question on this one what do you think
about if you just promoted like a five
percent across-the-board spending cut
for government employees you know II
just a salary cut and it would have yes
of course there would've been tremendous
brush back on it but it actually that
would have maybe been a tiny bit of a
dent of a number not just some oh I'm
giving 20,000 i don't think that that
would actually made a difference as far
as the real a real difference it's still
been symbolic but it actually would have
hurt government employees from people
who are government employees i I'd be
against that yeah they already put a
freeze he already did that BS we put a
freeze on raises for government
employees ready did that and so yet you
know Brock Obama um I'll just say that
people say well it's this Republican
they won't let anything happen they are
they're they're they're blocking
everything he wants to do well outsmart
them what the hell's the problem they're
not that bright how about try talks new
can outsmart want to does he want to
outsmart them I think that that question
is the question that everyone should be
asking Obama in the Obama administration
does he actually want to increase
revenue I mean does he want to tax the
wealthy like he's pretending like he
wants to it seems more like he wants to
make cuts to Social Security and
Medicare if he tax the wealthy anymore
they wouldn't have the forty thousand
bucks a plate it costs to go to one of
his fundraisers and that would not be
green oh yes he wants to prove these is
he's serious and then we all know the
only way you can prove you're serious is
to cut the social safety net from the
people who need it the most old and the
elderly and the sick bonobos calm is the
official outfitter of the Ruben report
enter code trr 20 for twenty percent off
your first purchase